e
e e
Horizon
and you you meet me here today mercies
that are
new and all my fears and
doubt they can all come to because they
can't stay long when I believe you
are the truth
the
light I believe it was the
way the
truth the
life I believe you
[Music]
are you are you are
it's a New
Horizon and we're set on
you and you meet us here today with
mercies that are
new and all our fears and
doubts they can all come
to because they can't stay
long when we're here with you
[Music]
I want to read a passage out of Isaiah
43 God's talking to
Israel and he says this is what the Lord
says he who made a way through the sea
and a path through the mighty
Waters forget the former things
don't dwell on the
past see I am doing a new thing now it
Springs up do you not perceive it I'm
making a way in the desert and streams
in the
Wasteland for I will pour out water on
thirsty land and streams on dry ground I
will pour out my spirit on your
Offspring and my blessings on your
descendants
we are
leaving crumbling
buildings full of
D full of
judgment we are
leaving violent
teaching from those who refuse to learn
from the best of
us we are
leaving crumbling
buildings full of D
and full of
[Applause]
judgments we are
leaving fireing
teaching from those refuse to learn from
the of
us we are
leaving crumbling
building full of dust
and full of
judgments we are
leaving violent
teachings from those Rie to learn from
the best of us
[Music]
we are
seeking holy healing
it full of Hope and it full of
Justice I've got a feeling that we're in
the middle of it I've got a feeling
she'll see us to the end of
it we are
seeking holy healing is full of Hope
full of
Justice I've got a feeling that we're in
the middle of it I've got a feeling
she'll see us to the end of
it we are
seeking holy healing is full of Hope B
full of Justice
I've got a feeling that we're in the
middle of it I've got a feeling you see
us to the end of
it we are
seeking holy healing is full of Hope and
is full of
justce I've got a feeling that we're in
the middle of it I've got a feeling
she'll see us to the end of
[Music]
it Scott would you see us to the end of
it would you be with us on this journey
God while we are in the messy middle
while we're figuring things
[Music]
out God would you open our hearts to the
new thing that you are doing would our
eyes be set on Jesus and your ways and
your work and your nature and your
character God would we be about those
things bringing that into our lives into
our communities into our world
God would we make space and room for
your spirit to do your good deep
[Music]
work God would we make room for
you thank you that your work is full of
hope your work is full of
light it's not one of shame or
condemnation
[Music]
God your work is good and
trustworthy would we sink ourselves into
[Music]
that into a love that changes
us into a love that calls out our best
[Music]
God make our hearts ready to respond to
your
move give us ears that are ready to
listen to your voice that know
[Music]
you Jesus we want more of
you less of me
more of
[Music]
you in Jesus name
amen would you guys go ahead and turn to
the people around you and say hello and
then BR will'll get us started
my name is Brett pronouns he him and uh
yeah a joy a joy to welcome you into
this and uh that includes those join us
online love you all a lots don't forget
to get your communion stuff uh whatever
you got available at the house you can
join us uh in that later and uh anyone
here tonight who is new thank you for
having the courage to walk through those
doors and and join us I know uh it can
just take a lot of Courage coming into a
new church community so um thank you
thank you for that and I I do hope you
find a uh a god of love a Christ of
compassion a community of Welcome uh
here at the table so um before we jump
in I I wanted to I just felt like I
needed to name something I write my
sermons a few you know like a week or so
in advance so um it was before I wrote
this before the inauguration and um you
all know for those who've been here a
while you know I'm I'm very uh kind of
sensitive
to the the danger and essence
of kind of doing to others what they
have done to me and done to us in in
kind of in the bad sense in the reverse
you know in the sense of like the
demonization um the
othering you know uh it would just be
very easy to kind of embody that you
know because many of us have been um
pretty excluded to put it
mildly and uh so you all know I I
wrestle with this and uh and yeah I I'm
attuned to not wanting to kind of do
that and we you know have here um you
know in our community folks who are more
politically conservative you know and of
course just by nature of who we are it's
um probably you not the majority but
it's still those folks are here and I I
don't want them to like feel othered and
somehow you know like get out you know I
I don't want that uh at the same time I
do feel this is a it's a unique moment
it's a unique um a unique conservative
president I'll put it that way and uh
that I think is being fairly gentle and
uh you know many of us are nervous
really nervous about what the future
holds
um for lgbtq folks um especially trans
people not not only but especially our
trans friends and
um and I also think of uh immigrants and
and we again that's folks not just like
in theory or something like those are
folks who are here part of our community
um some of them you don't realize that's
their background or their history
because of course they keep it quiet you
know uh and it's it's amazing that i'm
having conversations with some of our
leaders and folks about like do we need
to put signage on the front about you
know letting ice know they're not
welcome here and doing raids here in
this space you know like like it's just
astounding to me that I'm having these
conversations you know what I mean like
sorry now I'm getting all word I like
what is going on you know what I mean so
man I I just um yeah I think my heart is
I just want I I want you to know if you
are feeling in like you're on the
margins and uh you're in a group of
people that you feel othered and you
feel excluded in in all those ways I
just want you to know we love you we're
standing with you we care and I think as
as difficult and scary at times as this
is this is a tremendous opportunity for
us to walk this out together to support
one another right it can all be that's
where sermons and Christian IDE is can
all be just so idea you know
abstractions oh love one another blah
blah blah you know like this is where
the rubber meets the road you know this
is where like we start to put that stuff
into action so um yeah I just want to
name that we like were there with you
and we're going to walk this out and
we'll also be kind of as individuals I
did a whole politics series before the
election we you can go back and listen
to if you'd like where I was wrestling
through what to do and I do think
there's times you know for a good
trouble as it's been said and we'll be
Discerning you know what is that what
does that look like as individuals as
Community um what what's needed what's
the spirit calling forth you know while
at the same time right these things we
got to think these things together not
getting into reverse othering and not
demonizing and painting with broad brush
strokes and you know I mean like uh
those people or something like that's no
no that we can't slip into that um at
the same time so um yeah anyway I just
felt the need to name it it just felt
very weird to like go into my sermon
like not address that it's been a bit of
a dumpster fire of a week so um yeah all
right with that in mind we're in the
season of epiphany right now in the
church calendar for those um unfamiliar
with that this is like it's basically
it's sort of in ways a kind of a very
like evangelism kind of thing in the
sense of like is about the revelation of
Christ right so you have Advent it's
like in the Christmas tide where Christ
is born and now it's kind of like the
inbre of his ministry the the uh the the
kickoff and the Light of Christ in the
world and what does it mean for us you
know and so a lot of the passages are
very you know kind of revelatory and uh
those kinds of it just has those tones
you know even if they're not addressing
like saying you know Jesus or uh at all
like the text tonight for example isn't
like that it's a Psalm but you can kind
of still get pick up the the tones you
know of epiphany and and all that so um
with that in mind the title of my
message this week is paradox and
silence and uh our reading is from Psalm
19 verses
1-4 and it says this the heavens declare
the glory of God the skies proclaim the
work of his hands day after day they
pour forth speech night after night they
reveal knowledge they have no speech
they use no word words no sound is heard
from them and yet their voice goes out
into all the
Earth their words to the ends of the
world it's a
beautiful beautiful passage uh
mysterious as well I think um it's kind
of beautiful in its very uh sort of Rich
the rich language it has you know very
of course poetic as the Psalms you are
uh very poetic kind of I think it like
good poetry it kind of evokes feelings
in us a certain expansiveness I mean who
has not stood under the night sky and
felt a sense of you know something you
know a sense of kind of awe or wonder uh
who who hasn't been kind of moved by
that vastness and loveliness who who
hasn't uh kind of encountered the beauty
of creation and felt a certain I don't
know like a wooing or a a call you know
from the Creator so yeah there's a
certain Beauty in this text uh but
there's also a tremendous
mystery and we're alerted to it by the
presence of
paradox and um I want to name although
tonight we're kind of talking about
Psalm
19 in many ways I think this whole
approach I'm giving you kind of an
approach to scripture as in a way so
really it could be Psalm 19 but it could
be just any other passage anytime
there's like
Paradox or
poetry or even metaphor which honestly
when you're talking
theology there's a lot of metaphor in
the Bible you know Essence like I say
this word but I'm not using it at the
literal level it's pointing to something
else you know and I mean honestly almost
maybe all of our language about God it's
metaphorical why cu God is not like an
object in the world like a thing that
it's like oh look there it is and it's
this and it's that and it's this and
it's that and it's that and it's that
you know like this chair I could
describe oh it's purple and you know it
has this metal and it's like that's
literal and and it's not you wouldn't
say oh how poetic you know she like no
I'm just describing the chair but that's
the trick when it's God when it's
theology it's a lot of metaphor so I'm
hoping to kind of give us some kind of
an angle on um what to do when we're
encountering this kind of language how
does it invite us to read so we're kind
of alerted to this mystery to this need
for kind of a different way of thinking
and reading by In this passage is the
presence of paradox right you have in
verse one this language the heavens
declare the glory of God this guys
proclaim the work of his hands day after
day they pour forth their speech night
after night they reveal knowledge so you
can see it with all those words right
declare procla claim speak reveal you
say Oh see it's so literal well that's
what's tricky right if you we keep
reading verse three and yet what they
have no
speech they they use no words no sound
no sound at all is heard from them and
yet and yet their voice goes out into
all the Earth their words to the end
of the world right so no speech no words
no
sound so that's the Paradox right and a
paradox isn't a contradiction it's
something that appears to be a
contradiction but actually isn't why
because it's language that's not
operating at the literal level if it
were literal well then it would just be
gibberish but it's it's not there's
something else going on right so it
declares without declaring it proclaims
without proclaiming it speaks right
communicates without actually speaking
reveals without a sound not even a
whisper I'm going to talk for just a few
minutes on some
Neuroscience if
um it might shoot the wheels off this
sermon I don't know we'll see um if you
were here like a year ago so or so I
talked about IG Gilchrist and some of
his work and so I'm G to kind of bring
some of that back in because I just I
really think it becomes very
Illuminating uh for this so bear with me
um so I got a name I was just blown away
by this work by E mcgilchrist his book
The Master in his Emissary when I first
preached on this all I had read was
quotes and seen interviews with him and
since then I've actually like read the
book and oh babies it is it's a good one
um so in it he basically talks about how
we have uh you could call it sort of two
minds or two brains um it's really
technically two hemispheres right one
brain but then two hemispheres connected
by the Corpus colossum right this kind
of connector between in the middle and
uh early on scientists were I'd say they
were much more interested in the left
kind of hemisphere um mostly because it
seemed to be kind of the like the
primary driver of like the things we
really value in the modern world so for
example it's the left hemisphere that
does a lot of your like super
higher reasoning like
mathematics and kind of linear logical
reasoning it's also the left that again
all this is primary it's not so much
saying only the left hemisphere is
involved in this you know it's not quite
that it's more like it mainly does this
and then the right hemisphere does
something or contributes in a way but
mainly right so with the hemispheres
it's rarely like it only does this it's
more emphasis so right so mainly kind of
logical reasoning um again with language
it's the primary language thing there is
some language and word kind of
processing the right but um yeah the
left is really mainly um words and uh
also it's um it even kind of allows us
to use our hands like in the fine motor
skills way this is why most people are
right-handed because you have left
hemisphere if you know about the the
hemispheres it kind of corresponds to
the opposite side of the body so you've
got right hand right and that's what
we're best most people are best with uh
in terms of their kind of ability to do
things like you know typing or
woodworking um so that's where
scientists initially they're like oh the
left hemisphere that's where it it'sa
and they really thought they're right
they're like what is this doing you know
it's sort of like H um but over time
things have really shifted they've
they've started to realize like h no no
this is uh actually that right
hemisphere real important and what they
noticed was that as they started to
study stroke victims so if you were
going to have a stroke honestly you
would rather have a left hemisphere
stroke as a goes to a right now this
seems a little bit odd on its surface
because
outwardly you would look much more
inhibited so to speak if you had that
left hemisphere right
language is like wo real shut down you
know uh fine motor skills and movement
and using your hands and all that oh
really inhibited so outwardly you'd be
like oh no this was devastating the
worst kind of stroke you know left
hemisphere uh but actually no and uh the
reason is that actually it's the right
hemisphere that to put it a little bit
poetically kind of makes us
human in the sense of it's the right
hemisphere that's involved in deep
understanding in knowledge
formation right the left kind of puts it
into words but what good are words if
you like aren't really deeply
understanding you know it's sort of like
well somewhat useless right it's the
right hemisphere that can both make and
understand art and music and painting
it's the right hemisphere that plays the
dominant role in emotion and
feeling when the left hemisphere looks
at a thing this is really odd but
they've done studies where they ask
someone with a say a right hemisphere
stroke to draw right so all they have is
the left and they really struggle all
they see is
parts parts of things for example they
see a tree but they don't see the tree
they just
see sticks you know just pieces
fragments fractured dead things because
it's the right that perceives the whole
it's similar even with human beings you
see a human being and imagine if you
just saw sort of a monster like parts
body parts hanging together it's like
something from a horror movie you know
but why because it's the right
hemisphere that actually perceives the
whole perceives the whole human being
makes sense of
it there's a few quotes from a Gilchrist
I have to kind of try and sum this up a
little bit he says it also turns out
that the capacities that help us humans
form bonds with others empathy emotional
understanding and so on which involve a
quite different kind of attention paid
to the world are largely right
hemisphere functions he continues the
right hemisphere takes whatever is said
within its enti entire context it's
specialized in pragmatics the art of
contextual understanding of meaning and
in using metaphor it's the right
hemisphere which processes the
nonliteral aspects of language this is
why the left hemisphere is not good at
understanding the higher level meaning
of
utterances and so what mcris kind of
goes on to name is
that kind of strangely he kind of steps
back and analyzes society and he says
you know it's weird we live in a very
left hemisphere dominated
society which is why we are all about
logic and Systems and Technology and
tools and literalness and
control but he says it's beginning to
come at the expense of the right
hemisphere which understands what
context and metaphor and emotions and
empathy and love and art and music and
intuition and creativity in other words
it's the right hemisphere or the right
brain we might call it that deeply
understands
religion God it's only the right
hemisphere that if you're wondering what
does it have to do with Psalm 19 well
it's only the right hemisphere that
understands Psalm 19 in any way right
it's only that right him that that part
of you that here that poetry and says ah
yes I some part of me gets what this is
pointing
to the left brain says what a strange
assortment of words hear without
hearing speak without speaking this is
literally the stupidest thing I've ever
heard right the the left hemisphere just
doesn't
get it just doesn't get it and I think
this is why honestly modern society in
many ways just sort of as everyday
passes just increasingly just doesn't
get religion in general just you know
Christianity or anything else it's just
like what is going on
here in other words it's like to enter
the mystery of what it means to for
example I mean just think of this these
metaphors to take on the mind of Christ
to enter into the great mystery of being
one with God to be able to read Psalm 19
and intuitively get it to have a kind of
intuitive Faith or trust or loving
relational to connection to God a deep
knowledge of god notice not just
technical information or facts God facts
this is where I think the idea of um
treating the Bible like as some sort of
manual a manual for living
that's like the most modern left
hemisphere thing ever like let's turn it
into a users manual you know he terrible
oh my gosh it's awful um like in essence
what we're going to have to do is begin
to develop our right brain every bit as
much as we are in this culture
developing our left but of course the
trick is that in a left hemisphere
dominated
Society what has the trick Church done
as I just kind of hinted at we've become
much more left hemisphere
dominated right Bible studies
theological studies Sunday school books
podcasts information
ideas right spiritual growth where we're
kind of in the driver's seat you know we
control it just take this class and
you'll
grow read the Bible cover to cover take
in the information then it will work
right this is a very left hemisphere
approach to spiritual formation to be
clear I'm kind of trying to swing the
pendulum here so believe it or not I'm
not saying actually the left hemisphere
is problematic or bad or any of those
things are like problematic or bad in
and of
itself it's
problematic when it's not
balanced when it's not
deepened when it's not
enriched by the right hemisphere in its
practices so this leads us to something
called um I'm going to call it the
negative way or it's also known as the
apophatic path of spiritual growth so we
start off with what um theologians call
the cataphatic path or the positive way
this would be the way of doing things
you know we like to do things like hey
memorize this verse memorize this list
of books of the Bible our kids ministry
is doing that right now like it's
beautiful right it's good like hey
memorize these things like let's get
some Basics here you know this is good
this is good stuff uh study this pray
this prayer and exactly this way so we
start off there it's good but all the
great Saints and mystics say that
because we're dealing with
God
eventually words just start falling
short the way one writer puts it is that
God can be grasped by love
but by
knowledge
never with words never you see naming
God adding words to God is never
actually naming God in a literal
way right it's only really naming our
kind of current understanding of God the
the best we can do right now at this
time right it's it's naming our
understanding that but the truth is God
is always Beyond beond and so the the
negative
path the apatha that's actually the
shest way to an actual felt sense of the
love of God but of course it's the way
that almost no one
travels let me summarize it like this
the positive way the the cataphatic path
would be practices like scriptural study
and Theological study taking in
information via podcasts and books and
other mediums journaling about
information and ideas not so much the
feelings side that starts getting right
hemisphere all right so that's all kind
of left hemisphere dominant right the
negative way though is very different by
negative I don't mean bad you know or
sad the sad way you know it's not that
uh it's it's more like if the cataphatic
if the that kind of positive way is
about you doing
things the negative way the the
apathetic that's about spiritual growth
where you get out of the
way get out of the way get out of your
own way you might say and let the spirit
of God do her thing within you one a
metaphor that might be helpful here is
kind of the difference
between learning or reading the menu at
a
restaurant and actually
eating right these are different things
menus are wonderful very helpful but
kind of
pointless if you like never actually eat
the food right and so the negative way
is where you actually begin to eat the
menu can be words and
ideas but knowing about food memorizing
its components that's all very left
hemisphere
oriented a similar met for might be um
that of like a a prescription versus
taking a medication you say oh I've
studied I know all about this medicine I
know how it combines with other things I
know how it can impact you and you know
like my body I know it all you know and
the doctor's like did you take it did
you take the medication you're like no
I'm not really a medicine taker kind of
person I'm just more of a student of
medication you know it's like okay
okay so what does the taking the
medicine actually look like this would
be the negative way the apophatic it's
things like silence listening fasting
Solitude
meditation right these are hard for us
because again we like to be in the
driver's seat you know we like to know
like is it working is it working what am
I getting out of this the anonymous
writer of the 15th century Christian
mystical text The Cloud of Unknowing
uh we don't know who it was they said
these words they said he's not asking
for your help by he means god he's
asking for
you he wants you to lock your eyes on
him and leave him alone to work in you
your part is to protect the doors and
the windows of the senses keeping out
Intruders and flies
distractions or here's the words of
Christ in Matthew 6:6 but when you pray
go into Your Inner Room shut your door
and pray to your father who is unseen
and your father who sees what is done in
secret will reward
you there's a a story about the famous
desert father AB mes not like Moses of
the Old Testament he took his name from
him and uh a young man came to the
valley of skus there in the Egyptian
desert looking to become a Christian
monk so in kind of keeping with that
tradition he went to uh ABA Moses kind
of looking for um uh a word a word would
be like a a word of like advice or
perspective or something to kind of
contemplate or chew on you know so uh he
shows up and says oh AB Moses oh Elder
please please give me a
word and AA Moses said this go sit in
your cell
it's like your monks will room go sit in
your cell and your cell will teach you
everything that's like the most
apathetic response ever it's the type of
response that the left hemisphere freaks
out at like again that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard how is silence and
nothingness going to teach me anything
you know like what but that that's the
whole
thing uh I've told this story before but
um when I was in seminary back in 2014
one of my professors said uh in class
was spiritual formation class we're were
teaching all sorts of uh practices you
know scripture reading kind of
devotional type stuff um journaling all
sorts of practices and he said I have
just one more practice for you I know
none of you will do it but um just one
more thing I'd like to request you all
do I want you to take 30 minutes and
just sit quietly
in solitude and silence each
day that was interesting because he gave
no
methods no like like what do you like
what do you want us to do like is it
like a is like a follow the breathing
kind of thing you know is it is like a
mantra like a Jesus prayer kind of
eastern North like what's what's going
on NOP gave no advice no input just go
and shut up and sit quietly
and
um I I can say this I I've not sat every
day um and I've not always sat for 30
minutes uh but I've done my best and
it's been 10
years and I I can
say
oh oh it'll teach
you you you will begin to
learn learn about your own mind
distractions the crazy all the things
that kind of hold you back from the
presence of God and you'll start to
learn about the peace the peace that
passes all understanding the presence of
God but again it's like the difference
between a menu in actually eating food
or a prescription in the medicine it
can't really put it into words you know
no one can like teach to you in some
deeper sense you know it it can't be
transmitted in that way it's it's got to
be experienced and
lived now
in closing if you were here um last week
you might be thinking like well this is
all in contradiction your advice there
you said uh pick up something fresh
something fresh theology you know a book
a podcast a lecture begin to fill your
mind with it and uh that's true and yes
it was VE a very left hemisphere kind of
sermon and
um and that is what it is you know I
think it's fine the point of this
message though is not again that the
left hemisphere is like bad or wrong or
you know like throw out all books never
read the Bible again or like no no
that's not that's not what I'm saying um
instead what I do want you to maybe
frame it like this I want you all of us
to begin to study yourself kind of full
and then pray yourself empty in other
words take in the
information take in Engage The
cataphatic Path the positive way take in
even um not just scripture and reading
and podcast but like even just
experiences and life and movies and
literature and and conations with people
over coffee and you know like take in
life and all its diversity and all that
there's something beautiful to be said
for that study yourself full but that's
only half the equation then you got to
pray yourself
empty then you got to enter into
silence see because you need the right
hemisphere to make sense of it all we
might say that the left hemisphere feeds
the right hemisphere information but
it's the right hemisphere that absorbs
and actually incorporates it into my
life okay so you say Brett what do you
want me to do this is what I want you to
do I just want you to Simply sit or
stand or
lay in silence for 15 minutes a
day don't say words not during that time
other times you can say words just
during that 15 minutes don't say words
don't pray for others in terms of like a
trying to like oh I lift up this person
that person like no no it's not what
this time's about don't pray for others
don't read the scriptures don't sip
coffee don't listen to a guided
meditation although it's fine you know
again outside of this you can do it
another time just right now just
quiet just sit or stand or lay and when
you notice the mind going off into La La
Land and it will just bring it back
bring it back to the quiet the quiet
awareness of the presence of God over
time you'll get the hang of it you may
even feel invited to kind of
lengthen those times and uh if you do go
with it that's great follow your
intuition follow the leading of the
spirit in that way and then over time it
will teach you everything over time you
will come to know not just as
information but as hardfought for
knowledge a knowledge of the
heart of the Deep
Mind how it is that the heavens declare
the glory of God and the skies proclaim
the work of his hands you'll come to
know God not as an idea but as a loving
presence pervading all
things in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen
so on the night Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples and at that meal he held up a
for bread and he broke it and he said
take it eat this is my body it's broken
for you and then he held up a cup of
wine he said take it drink this is my
blood it's shed for you whenever you eat
this bread whenever you drink this cup
remember me and so for a few thousand
years now that's what Christians have
done we've come to gather at the table
to take in Christ a very right
hemisphere kind of thing because this
makes no sense at the literal at the
literal level
um so you know as you come forward
tonight there could be a lot of burdens
a lot a lot of things you're carrying I
I encourage you to kind of come forward
in just a an open like a place of just
openness just open ready to receive uh
whatever it is that God has for you so
the way we'll um kind of go about this
is we'll just go row by row starting
here at the front and we'll just form
one line so when kind of one row is
about done the next row can get up and
uh take their place uh you should know
that the red is wine the white is grape
juice uh you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like some folks like
to come and kneel here at the front some
return to their seats to partake um some
just take immediately but no one will
lead you through the exact moment of
taking so you just kind of do that um on
your own and then finally we practice an
Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you'd like to participate
then you are you're free to do that so
this is the table not the church but of
the Lord and it's made ready for those
who love him and for those who want to
love him more so
come come you who have much faith and
you who have little you who have been
here often and you who have not been
here long you who've tried to follow and
you who feel like you failed come come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the table
[Music]
for
if you guys want to stand with us as we
close out with this last song we going
to sing this as sort of a practice of
opening our hands letting go and um and
giving our the things that we want so
badly to control over into the hands of
Jesus who is very capable of holding it
all for us
God we bring you the work of our hands
and now lay it down lay it at your
feet where we've done where we buil
where we
broken lay it down lay it in your
feet you hold it
Jesus you
[Music]
hold wored Hearts weed heads weaken
bodies lay it down lay it down your
feet we used were we lost were we
wased lay it down lay it at your
feet you hold it all Jesus you
hold
it you
Jesus you
[Music]
holy all our dreams all our plans our
Ambitions lay it down lay it at your
feet and even if nothing comes
to lay it down lay it at your feet
lay it down lay it
at your
[Music]
feet thank you so much for joining us
this
evening um if you were new we would love
for you to fill out a card at our little
table in the wayout or you can scan the
QR code on the screens and fill out the
online visitors
card um if you're looking for more
relational support or spiritual
connection we have meetup groups um
that's how we do it here at the table um
if you are not part of a Meetup Group
once again please scan the QR code find
one that works for
you um tonight we have a trans 101 class
after service and we'll meet back here
after a short break let things get reset
everybody get cover comfortable again um
but that'll be right back here in the
sanctuary um in probably about 15 20
minutes um generosity is a key aspect of
life of adoration and worship if the
table is your church home then we invite
you to scan the QR code and give
financially or visit the TBL tx.org
let me send you out this week with a
blessing so if you can hold your hands
in a posture to receive or just open
your heart to these
words you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and it
is true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted just as you
are go filled with God's holy spirit and
desire to extend those same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with be blessed and
we'll see you next
[Music]
Sunday dream all our plans our
ambition lay it down lay it your
feet and even if nothing comes to
lay it down lay it your feet you
hold you
hold Jesus you hold
it you
hold all Jesus you
hold it all
all our dreams all our PLS
our lay them
down
your even nothing comes
to lay it down lay it at your
feet lay it down lay it
at your feet
[Music]
guys